hello
my name is shalini lonam i am an
assistant professor of chemistry and
physics here at purdue university
and i definitely want to start by
thanking the organizers for the
invitation to speak and also all of the
coordination efforts that have gone into
making this all possible so that even in
a virtual context we can still have
great interactions
so today i'll be talking about work from
largely my group here at purdue but also
some work from my postdoc at uc berkeley
on the topic of understanding t cell
activation by using single molecule
methods
so i'll start by playing this video
acquired by my student kevin
that shows the remarkable behaviors of
chimeric antigen receptor t cells
and in this case primary cars that are
sampling a
breast cancer cell and you can see that
these spherical cells come and interact
with this large flat cell
and in fact quite remarkably in the case
of the the main activity you can see
here this t cell actually burrows
underneath the the tumor cell
and it clearly shows that there can be
some robust interactions between these
two different cell types and we know
that the development of cars has been
an exciting new area of
treatment option for certain cancers
that may give robust killing
given that they can be
developed from one's own immune system
so i'll start by acknowledging my
graduate student kevin
who has been just absolutely fantastic
over the last couple of years and he
certainly represents the greatest
accomplishment in building my lab since
i started here at purdue in 2019 he is
an incredibly industrious individual and
has just a great spirit for imaging and
for collaborative work
so his accomplishments are are really
fantastic and i'm grateful for
everything he contributes
our lab does work in the area of
biochemistry and biophysics and
particular in particular focuses at
interactions at cell cell junctions
because a lot of important reactions
occur at these membrane membrane
interfaces and the membrane itself
serves as a reaction landscape
it's also important to remember that
very often the critical activities that
are happening at these interfacial
spaces involve only small numbers of
molecules and that's not just the
ligands and receptors that may be
interacting
but even the downstream signaling
molecules it may in fact be the
activities of very small numbers of
molecules that are actually most
influential in the overall behavior
and furthermore that you can get
heterogeneous outcomes from genetically
identical cells which is to say that
even as we start to develop these
therapeutics based on chimeric antigen
receptor t cells it could in fact be the
case that the activities of small
numbers of cells actually dominate the
overall outcome of the system
the mechanics are also really important
in these spaces where these tortured
membrane interfaces and the stiffness of
the local environment can really impact
the success of signaling and so in
trying to think about all of these
themes we start with a beautiful example
which is the t cell itself and during my
postdoc at uc berkeley with jay groves
we really focused on t cells which are
fundamentally single molecule detectors
and so what you see here is a depiction
of the interface between an antigen
presenting cell or apc and a living t
cell
and importantly the activating
information that is transmitted from one
to the other occurs at this junction
between the t cell receptor which is
shown in purple and it's ligand peptide
mhc so peptides from antigenic molecules
that are presented on major
histocompatibility complexes
and just single binding events between
tcrs and pmhcs are sufficient to kick
off signaling
within the t cell that lead to decision
making outcomes but remarkably these
single binding events must create robust
signaling in the context or background
of cellular noise and ensure that the t
cell can d
quickly discriminate and act on small
numbers of activating events because of
course a t cell mostly encounters in its
native context self antigens and yet
must respond to foreign antigens very
very sensitively
and given that they are these beautiful
single molecule detectors one might
wonder how we try to get information
across a population of cells and so
the importance of understanding single
cell can be underscored by thinking
about an experiment like flow cytometry
where we can quickly get lots of
information about say tens of thousands
or maybe even millions of cells but of
course we only have a snapshot from an
instant in time
and so we would argue that there's a lot
of additional information that is in the
underlying kinetic that we can better
appreciate
by gaining additional dimensionality to
the data at the single cell and single
molecule level but in the particular
case of a t cell single molecule is
additionally important given what i just
mentioned about this initiation of
signal by small numbers of ligands even
just a ligand so here is a classical
example from the davis lab
at stanford where you can see that a
single pmhc which is this bright red dot
that you can see is actually sufficient
over several binding events with a
living t cell to actually produce
cytokine il2
and so this idea of single molecule
detection within a population of cells
and the possibility for heterogeneous
outcomes really underlies why we want to
understand the fundamental mechanisms
that give rise to these population
behaviors
and we have a really strong history that
we can rely on because of the cellular
biochemistry that has been done over
many decades in the context of t cell
biology
and what you can see here
is the biochemical signaling cascade
that has been developed such that we can
see that tcr pmhc binding so between the
green receptor and cyan ligand kicks off
a series of intracellular events largely
through phosphorylation cascades
that creates signaling assemblies
templated like on the molecule lat that
you can see shown in red
and eventually leading to downstream
signaling and translocation of
transcription factors like urcan and fat
furthermore there's really important
information in the physical arrangement
here at this junction between the t cell
and the antigen presenting cell because
of the changes in the landscape that
occur when these ligation events
are encountered because you can see on
the right hand side of the screen
that
larger molecules like cd45 which is a
phosphatase and
adhesion molecules like the interaction
between lfa and icam are actually
excluded from the space based on their
size so again the idea of the membrane
as a reaction landscape becomes really
important as we think about the
underlying activities that are setting
the decision-making criteria and what i
mean by that is for a long time it's
been uncertain what actually sets the
threshold for a t cell to activate and
so we started trying to understand this
problem using normal t cells even before
thinking about engineered ones
so i'll briefly discuss how we
translate these very complex problems
that involve three-dimensional junctions
between t cells and target cells
to approximate just the inter-membrane
space and gain as much high resolution
information as we can
so on the left you saw a very short
video of a t-cell sampling the surface
of tumor cell in the middle you see the
schematic of the typical junction formed
between a t cell and an antigen
presenting cell what we can do is we can
approximate this by replacing the
antigen presenting cell with a supported
lipid bilayer that is glass supported
and the benefit of this is that by
having a mobile bilayer that we can
derivatize with any molecules that we
would like and any densities we would
like we can then create a scenario where
we can gain a lot of information through
direct visualization using microscopy of
events that are occurring at that
interface and so the video that's
playing on the right is showing you the
footprint or the contact area between a
living t cell and the supported lipid
bilayer shown in the ricm channel
and then the icam yfp channel that you
see in the lower left shows you the
adhesion that i had mentioned very
briefly in the prior slide so you can
see that this contact area is rich in
interactions that are keeping the t-cell
on the bi-layer and i'll talk about the
binding events that are shown on the
right in a couple of slides
so by taking this reconstitution
approach where we have the interface
between a living cell and this synthetic
antigen presenting cell we now give
ourselves an opportunity to take
advantage of high special temporal
resolution imaging namely in a turf
configuration and what you can see in
this slide is that the freely mobile
brownian diffusion of individual pmhc
molecules are syringe occur on this
synthetic apc but upon interaction and
bona fide binding with the t cell
receptors of the living cell the
mobility that results from the bound
complex between t cell receptors and
pmhc leads to slowed mobility and that
change in mobility is something we can
directly measure as a reflection of the
binding events that are occurring
push to audience okay
so on this movie what you can see is
individually labeled peptides pmhcs that
are diffusing freely on the bilayer in
the upper left and you can see that they
have they undergo normal brownian
diffusion but in the presence of a cell
which is shown toward the upper right
and outline
skin
and outlined in cyan is that in the
presence of a cell there are in fact two
populations a fast-moving population and
a slowly diffusion diffusing population
which is in fact the bound events
so we can then select for the bound
receptors
simply by elongating the exposure time
and therefore as you see in the lower
right things that are moving quickly are
blurred and only those binding events
that are occurring on this time scale
are clearly resolved
so by taking advantage of that
information we can now individually
watch the binding events that are
encountered by a single living t cell
and this is important because it gives
us information about when a signaling
cascade may be kicked off so i revisit
this cartoon of the biochemistry of tcr
signaling to remind you that once you
have bound receptors a number of
downstream events are possible and a
cellular response is possible
but in order to try and answer the
fundamental question of what activates a
t cell we tried to simplify this idea
using an analog to signal processing so
we take the idea that this could be an
impulse response function and by
impulses i mean discrete pieces of
information that go into the system so
here our system is going to be the cell
and these impulses can be modulated
either in amplitude or in frequency that
is how strong an interaction might be a
binding event or how frequently they
might be encountered
and this black box is in fact all of the
cellular biochemistry that's happening
in the cell that is so complex and
difficult to measure but critical to the
transformation process that the cell
will then act on to create a response or
the input output response function
what's really beautiful about this
response is we can imagine that by
measuring the individual binding events
that a t cell experiences and without
measuring all of the intracellular
complex biochemistry
if we can determine that the cell did
something made a decision and in this
case we take the binary response of
translocation of a transcription factor
and fat into this
we now can determine the transformation
through
extraction rather than through direct
observation
so it's easiest to understand this by
actually seeing it in the context of a
movie and what you'll see in the movie i
will play is this ricm channel which
again shows us membrane topography so we
will see living t cells come and land on
the bilayer
and in the middle channel the pmhc ato
channel this is where the inputs are
being measured so each of the binding
events that the t cell experiences
and then finally on the right-hand
channel in the n-fat we can see the
translocation of the transcription
factor and fat into the nucleus and as i
mentioned this is a binary decision so
once the transcription factor goes into
the nucleus that cell is committed to
activating
and so we'll watch this process uh in
the movie and then i'll make a couple
comments after that
so here we see the cell land
and it spreads
and forms an interface that we see here
in ricm we can see the circled binding
events in red and then over time we'll
notice that the n-fat goes from the
cytoplasm into the nucleus and that
translocation demonstrates it
demonstrates that this cell has
activated
it may be a little easier to look at
these data in a more static sense so
here's a montage of that same movie and
i'll point out a couple of really
important features the first is that we
can directly visualize the process of
cell landing that precedes binding
events and the decision-making process
thereby having the complete history of
information that this cell experienced
so we know the moment it started
interpreting information from its local
environment what those information
looked like in terms of single molecule
binding events and ultimately whether or
not the cell activated
so all these pieces of information allow
us to have a timeline
as well as spatial information about all
of the impulses that went in as well as
their response and one could imagine
that by knowing the impulses in the
response we can get gather information
about the transformation
so here we can see all of that
information collapsed into a simple 3d
movie where the binding events are being
accumulated so the binding events shown
as magenta circles in the movie that's
playing
create information in the form of
three-dimensional trajectories in time
so each of the lines that you see in
this what we call spaghetti plot each of
the the noodles if you will shows you
where the bound events occurred in time
and in space for this particular cell
and you can also see in the topmost
plane in shown in green the activating
information in the form of the n-fat
translocation event so i'll go ahead and
play that one more time
so given this time evolution we have all
kinds of information about this cell
experienced
we can take these kinds of data
and then try to understand
what led to making the activating
decision
and remarkably the simplest hypotheses
fail so the simplest hypotheses would be
that the t cell counted the number of
binding events it experienced
or that it summed up the total time of
binding that it experienced and that
integrated binding time set the
activation threshold
in fact neither of these is the case and
rather what we found in the course of
this work is that t cells are paying
attention to both where and when binding
events occur
so keep in mind that more often than not
binding events are very short because
real agonist ligands have low affinities
that are very almost indistinguishable
from self ligands and so in fact what
you can see in the schematic on the left
is if you were to imagine one bound
trajectory shown in blue that is
experienced for some amount of time and
then it disengages and another binding
event shown in red that over some sort
of temporal window follows the blue
event and it's also somewhat nearby in
space what we call the spatial
neighborhood
in fact what appears to happen is the t
cell artificially stitches these two
events together
and interprets it as one very long
binding event and from a biochemical
perspective there's a good intuition
here that the longer the binding event
the greater the amplitude of signal
because the longer time there is for
biochemical reactions to occur and so
quite remarkably we were able to show
that in fact what a t cell does in
making an activating decision is use
these multiply correlated tracts so what
you see here in this simplified
schematic is the idea that shown in gray
boxes are the amplitudes of signal
in the context of non-activating cells
we can see that short binding events
lead to low amplit or short small
amplitude signals whereas long binding
events or these binding events that are
spatio temporally correlated as you see
on the far right can sustain greater
signal and lead to activation
so again i want to emphasize a couple of
features about this impulse response
assay the first is that we can see both
activating and non-activating cells and
this is really important because it
allows us to distinguish threshold
activities for those cells that do make
a decision say to activate and those
that do not
and then finally even though there is
this spatiotemporal correlation it's
quite interesting that the scales of
these correlations are larger than we
might immediately predict
so events that are within about two
microns in space and 30 seconds in time
can be stitched together and i don't
have time to talk about the underlying
machinery but we also have newer data
hopefully in an upcoming publication
that show that this lat molecule that i
briefly mentioned earlier may be
mediating this spatiotemporal
correlation but ultimately what i want
to go on to is the discussion of what
does this mean in the context of
chimeric energy t cells and so this is
the work that we've been expanding since
i moved to purdue
where you can imagine that now by
knowing that t cells are capable of
spatiotemporal correlation we could
imagine the same might be true for
engineered t cells but if it's not we
would probably want to know this in
order to better engineer
robust responses moving forward
the idea here is that by having an
artificially engineered receptor that
can recognize a tumor cell you could
create an activation cascade within a t
cell from a patient that then leads to
one of two types of activation either
mobilizing adaptive responses from other
cells or perhaps directly killing the
target tumor cell
and so we still ask the underlying
question what are the molecular features
that control this activation
and it'd be tempting to think that these
chimeric inogen receptor t cells signal
exactly like a tcr but in fact we have
plenty of evidence that they are quite
different the first is that that
canonical structure that i talked about
that allows for concentration of bound
tcr's at the center and other binding
events of larger physical dimension like
adhesion
that creates this structure called the
immunological synapse that you see in
the overlay where there are very tight
tcrs in the center and then icam bound
adhesion complexes uh in red outside
there there's plenty of evidence that in
a chimeric antigen receptor t cell
context this very well known structure
of the immunological synapse does not
exist
and so already there are good reasons to
think that cars signal differently and
that we need to better understand how
they are signaling
so in partnership with phil loudlab here
at purdue we've been taking advantage of
an engineering strategy that phil's lab
has developed
and so this takes advantage of a
slightly different strategy that is
called a unicar so rather than a car
alone this universal strategy is based
on having cars that recognize
a single molecule fitzy which is not one
that you would see physiologically but
that by having that fizzy molecule on a
bridge here we show fitzy folate
then the folate or the folic acid binds
to the tumor itself and bridges between
the tumor and the car this carries the
the benefit that you could then have a
single population of cars that could be
targeted to many different cancers
simply by modifying the bridge
the other convenient thing is that since
fitzy is a fluorescent molecule it can
be used in laser-guided surgery because
as you can see toward the upper right by
having the fitsy folate within a tumor
you can see it glow and light up which
may also help in tumor resections
but with phil's lab what we're trying to
do is to understand
how a unicar actually a universal car
actually activates so what my student
has been doing
is creating bi-layer systems that have
the folate receptor on it displayed at
different densities and then using the
bridging multifolate and the anti-fitzy
car to better understand the activation
thresholds in several different
parameter spaces the effects of affinity
of both the car itself and of the bridge
the densities of the molecules which
could be the densities of the car
receptors on the surface the density of
the folate receptor
and then copy numbers and clustering so
of course as i mentioned very early on
small numbers of signaling molecules may
have large effects and so we're trying
to understand
using this reconstitution approach how
all of these different parameters fit
into the activation decision for a car
and you can see our impulse response
function
exemplified here where again we assume
that much of the biochemical signaling
is as it normally would be in a t cell
receptor system but have good reason to
think that there may be additional
pathways
that are in play because unlike a tcr a
chimeric engine receptor t cell is only
a single past transmembrane receptor so
it's fundamentally quite different than
a tcr
but our impulses of binding events
between
the car and the target folate
molecule on the folate receptor can then
lead to activation decisions in at least
two forms that we're thinking of right
now one is transcription factor
translocation as we've seen before in
other t-cell contexts as well as the
secretion of lytic molecules like
perforin and granzyme so these are
actually the prototypical molecules
secreted to actually kill target tumor
cells
and we're working to better understand
this impulse response function uh in the
context of breast cancer
another development that kevin has been
working on
is to try and increase the sampling of
the events that we are seeing so one
challenge that we faced in the early
development of the impulse response
function is the need to to capture the
but the landing and spreading of t cells
and i mentioned how powerful this
information is because it sets the full
timeline for that t cell but of course
it can be difficult to capture this
event
so kevin is also working on strategies
to increase the number of events that we
can visualize simultaneously through
larger fields of view and so you here
can see
t cells coming in and landing on a
bi-layer and you can beautifully catch
at least a few um maybe up to 10 or more
binding events
landing and spreading events for t cells
at the same time
as we try to directly look for single
molecule carb binding events as you'll
see in the next two movies we can watch
these very dynamic car t cells
using our reflection interference
contrast channel and we're getting very
close to having really beautiful data of
single molecule binding so i'll play
that in the next two movies
so here you can see a car on a bi-layer
and you can see it's membrane
fluctuations as it samples the
information around it just really
beautiful
t-cell interactions with the slb
and in this video you can start to see
binding events as these really bright
spots that are coalescing underneath
that t cell that we had just been
visualizing and so clear evidence that
these binding events are being
accumulated
so moving forward
we are now able to see these binding
events between the folate receptor and
the cars and where this is occurring in
time and space and this is giving us the
ability to start looking at these
impulse response functions and complex
signaling circuits in search of the key
thresholds for activation so that we can
better design cars and these signaling
circuits to maximize killing efficiency
but you might ask the question how does
this then translate back to the
three-dimensional context because of
course reconstitution does lack some of
the information that would occur at a
true cell cell junction
so in parallel we are also developing
systems that allow us to control
this 3d junction in such a way that we
can use living tumor cells and living
cars
where we now know the densities of
receptors on the surface of the tumor
and can look at the killing efficiency
by the cars directly thereby testing
some of the theories and models that
come out of our reconstitution methods
so hopefully a lot of exciting things
are on the horizon
my student has been doing an absolutely
fantastic job building up these systems
and we really are poised to measure the
impulse response function across many
orders of magnitude for many cells to
better understand how these cars are
being activated and what the threshold
criteria are
so with that
i'll thank the members of my group so
this is the current group
kevin being my main student ari another
graduate student through a collaboration
and our three undergrads and i often
tease my students that one of the skills
we have to learn in science is about
juggling and i'm really pleased uh that
they're all tackling this challenge as
difficult as it can be at times and
really doing a fantastic job trying to
become really great interdisciplinary
scientists
and finally it's really important to
also acknowledge the wonderful
collaborators and mentors that i've had
and continue to work with so jay groves
at uc berkeley i was with him when we
developed the impulse response function
and now we're getting to apply it here
at purdue with phil lao
and we have a host of other really
fantastic collaborators and many fun and
exciting things on the horizon
so thank you all for your attention
thanks again to the organizers for the
efforts and the invitation and i'll look
forward to future interactions and
questions